behind me is London City Airport built
on an old dock in East London they're
building a new control tower here to
replace the 30 year old one and to make
room for expansion but that new tower
won't have any people in it it'll just
be a tall mast with a lot of cameras the
people will be 18 miles away
we're in the London City option which
will go live in January 2020 and this is
where London City air traffic control
will be provided from London City does
not have a lot of space so the footprint
that's taken up by by this mast is
significantly less than it would be for
a traditional tower the digital can't be
cheaper it's significantly easier to
build you don't have to have any of the
functionality you need for people to be
a nurse or the no rest rooms kitchens
toilets using the augmentation on the
screen we can actually show them the
aircraft as a flying by the window with
the radar tags on it so they can see the
callsign the speed in the altitude and
we also have the Pantone zoom cameras
and fever you can look into the Sun to
track an aircraft who's traveling to the
south you'd never do that binoculars but
their system lets you do them this is a
360 panorama but it's compressed into
225 degrees
benefit for the controller is that they
can no longer need to look over the
shoulder to see a listeners passing
behind you no aircraft 30 miles 50 miles
on the approach you can see the lights
so the visibility and that this gives
you is much better than human eye the
data is compressed up sight and in its
squatted owner a couple of really big
pipes don't to sonic we specified that
lag has been less than one second which
is the same like that we have for voice
communications with pilots right now
that new control room is just used for
training the camera mast isn't built yet
so they're just using footage film from
a crane a few months ago now digital
control towers are already used at
smaller airports but this will be the
first one in a major city with this
level of air traffic something like this
doesn't just have to failsafe it has to
add no additional risk every control is
quite conservative by nature so they
have a little what-if in the back of the
head so what if a screen feels what if a
feat fails what if a camera feels all
these things were apparent in the design
and on top of each of the screens is a
little stay alive indicator so if it's a
quiet time of the day and there might
not be any traffic moving about you know
that you're still looking at the airport
you're not looking at a frozen picture
of the airport if you lose a screen the
system is clever enough to recognize it
the screen is filled it will then
transmit that image onto a space screen
we shuffle all the images to actually
give the controller their property view
and in engineers can arrive and change
giving them five or ten minutes if a
camera feels we have got the pancetta
zoom cameras on the top of the housing
which can actually replicate the view of
these camera that's field if it rains
that's compressed air that automatically
blows that rain away there's a bug
protection on top and you've also got
some heaters inside so it doesn't get
misty a frosty in the winter if the
cameras and their entirety fail we
effectively manage the transition as if
it was fog we still have a number of
backup routes so we have separate voice
communications to the airport which are
unaffected controllers can see and fog
you lose the cameras you can't see and
we just slowly manage that transition to
the same type of operation we are using
separate data feeds they come from the
masts one goes east one goes west
they're not public internet they don't
go into the cloud they're not going
through this induct so they are robust
and secure now I don't want this to
sound like a sponsored video it isn't
but having visited the new control
center yeah in the rational part of my
brain I'm convinced that it works and
it's safe
given the augmented reality overlays and
the extra height it might well be more
safe from the old tower but it still
feels a bit wrong and I don't have a
sensible reason why now there are plenty
of times that it just feels wrong can be
a good reason to avoid something bad
relationships walking down the dark
street at night your brain is good at
avoiding things that might hurt you but
air trouble something's so far outside
everyday experience where safety is so
important that can't be governed by
whether something feels right here the
evidence is pretty solid and if want a
flight out of here in 2020
I'll give the cameras away as a takeoff
tell me we got us